on this now i want to bring in former
acting customs and border protection
commissioner
mark morgan sir welcome back to our
program i want our viewers to see this
on screen now
uh the department of homeland security
projects for 2021.
at 117 thousand crossings
compared to last year with thirty three
percent yeah the pandemic then but going
back to nine
two thousand nineteen at eighty thousand
uh what's going on here sir
well bill so this is important and
listen to your own words that i agree
with
record numbers but you're just talking
about uacs let's talk
i i've jotted down a few stats getting
ready for this morning
so 117 000 unaccompanied minors but
we're also looking to project it at this
rate
of 1.4 million total individuals trying
to illegally enter this country
right now we're looking at almost 5 000
a day
that we are encountering unless on the
southwest border
illegally entering 400 of those are
unaccompanied minors
right now we don't talk about this right
now got a ways we're looking at almost
a thousand godaways because our borders
aren't secure if you extrapolate that
out by the end of this year we're
looking at two hundred and thousand
godaways
this is absolute crisis but yet this
week the secretary of dhs got in front
of
the american people and lied saying it's
a mere challenge rather than the crisis
that it is bill
well mark that you bring bring that up
we actually want to show you a little
bit of sound here i mean this
this is the case that there are some
democrats trying to sound the alarm but
many are not going to call it a crisis
they just say it's a challenge watch
the crisis was in 2014 the crisis was in
2019.
do we have a crisis right now the
snapshot right now
no are we getting there yes if we don't
make any changes
at what point does it become a crisis
well i would say i don't think we need
to meet your bar
of what we need to call it we are
approaching this humanely
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe just take the politics of it for a
second so when you are there as an
official
at customs and border patrol what is
your threshold level for a crisis
i'll go back to danny that's a great
question i'll go because this is not a
right or left thing
i'll go back when i was chief of the
border patrol under a democratic
administration under then secretary jay
johnson
who said quote his words not mine a
thousand was a bad day
and when i worked for him as the chief
believe me a thousand was a bad day
and if you go back to 2019 the same
democrats including representative
cuellar which i respect
he said in 2019 it was a crisis and
right now the numbers we're seeing
are exceeding or meeting the numbers
that we were experiencing back in 2019
it's a crisis then it's a crisis now
this is not a right or left thing
but how how they phrase it does depend
on which side of the aisle you stand on
right now and the american people
deserve better dana that's a great
question dana um the president's going
to be told that a number of migrant kids
is on pace
to exceed kids just now and you talk
about unaccompanied minors
to exceed the all-time record by 45
percent
well how do you stop that how do you
slow it down
and if you don't what's the short-term
resolution
the bill it's almost too late look this
administration within
30 days has assist well because this
administration
has absolutely dismantled and destroyed
every effective policy
that had reduced the flow like you said
this time last year
it is over a hundred percent increase in
minors alone
and you want to talk about cruelty look
we are this country right now bill is
actually encouraging
and facilitating and incentivizing moms
and dads and countries
in the western hemisphere to hand their
kids over to cartels and smuggler a
smuggling organization
to make the dangerous track during the
middle of a global pandemic
to illegally enter this country no this
country should not be doing that
we should be stopping this and right now
we need ags and and governors of states
to stand up and challenge these actions
in court that's the only way we're going
to be able to have an impact right now
that's a great point i mean i think
about that too in terms of the human
condition
and i know i know that many of the
migrants are are teens
okay but that's they're still children
um and
what a lot of them are going through and
i know the wrenching decision like to
tell your kid go for it but this is
unacceptable
and it is going to come back to hurt a
lot of people it will be a major not
just a political issue but is this it is
something that america is going to have
to deal with we cannot pretend it's not
a problem
yeah dana real quick and to your point
look right now
like you said it doesn't matter the
majority are 15 16 but but they're still
minors right
they are they are taking this dangerous
trek through mexico going through covet
hot spots
being in large groups which are mobile
petri covered petri dishes
they're being stuffed in over crowded
unsanitary stash houses
tractor trailers the list goes on and
like you just mentioned in your opening
a good portion of them are testing
positive for covid
this is unconscionable it's not okay
mark morgan thank you sir we're going to
check in with you later in the week
thank you for your time today you bet